what is a mixed model Anova what are the
hypotheses and assumptions and how to
interpret the results of a mixed model
Anova this is what we discussed in this
video let's start with the first
question what is a mixed model Anova a
mixed model an NOA is a statistical
method used to analyze data that
involves both between subject factors
and within subjects factors but what are
between subjects factors factors and
within subjects factors let's look at an
example let's say we want to test
whether different diets have an effect
on cholesterol levels we would like to
compare the three diets a b and c so
Defector diet has the three levels a b
and c to test whether there is a
difference between the diets we are
conducting a study with 18 participants
the individual participants are called
subjects now we random L assign six
participants to each of the three groups
each participant or subject is assigned
to only one group in this case we have a
between subjects Factor different
subjects are exposed to different levels
of a factor in this analysis our
objective is to determine whether
significant differences exist in the
mean cholesterol levels among the
various groups on the study and this is
exactly what a one way and over this now
of course we could also examine the
impact of one diet across multiple time
points we could measure the cholesterol
levels at each participant at the start
of the diet after 2 weeks and after four
weeks so the factor time has the three
level start two weeks and four weeks and
in this case the same subjects are being
exposed to all levels of the factor and
this is called a within subject Factor
the same subjects are exposed to all
levels or conditions in this case we
want to know if there is a difference in
the mean value of the cholesterol levels
between the different points in time and
this is exactly what a repeated measures
and NOA does therefore in a repeated
measures and NOA we have within subject
factors so in a between subjects design
each subject or participant is only
assigned to one one factor level so that
the different subjects only have the
influence of the respective group in
contrast in the within subject design
the same subjects or participants are
exposed to all Factor levels which
enables a direct comparison of the
reactions to each factor level but what
if we want to test if there is a
difference between Diet a b and c over
the different points in time so we want
to test if there is is a difference
between the diets and if there is a
difference between the different time
points then we need a mixed model and
NOA because we have both one between
subject factor and one within subject
Factor so in a mixed Moda Nova we have
at least one between subjects factor and
at least one within subjects factor in
the same analysis note a mixed modan
Nova is also called a two and NOA with
repeated measures because there are two
factors and one of them results from
repeated measures therefore the mixed
model and Nova test whether there is a
difference between more than two samples
which are divided at least between two
factors one of the factors is a result
of measurement repetition with the help
of a mixed model and NOA you can now
answer three things first whether the
within subject Factor has an effect on a
dependent variable second whether the
between subject Factor has an effect on
a dependent variable and third whether
there is a so-called interaction effect
between the two factors this gives us a
good transition to the hypothesis the
first null hypothesis is the mean values
of the different measurement times do
not differ there are no significant
differences between the groups of the
within subject Factor then of course
there is the second the means of the
different groups of the between subject
Factor do not differ and the third n
hypothesis reflects the interaction
Effect one factor has no effect on the
effect of the other Factor what are the
assumptions of a mixed model Nova
normality the dependent variable should
be approximately normally distributed
within each group of the dependent
variables this assumption is especially
important when a sample size is small
when a sample size is large a Nova is
somewhat robust to violations of
normality homogeneity of variances the
variances in each group should be equal
in mixed model Anova this needs to be
true for both the within subjects and
between subjects factors the leine STS
can be used to check this assumption
homogeneity of co-variances sphericity
this applies to the within subject's
factors and assumes that the variance of
the differences between all combinations
of the different groups are equal what
does that mean let's start with the
differences between all combinations to
do this we simply need to calculate the
difference of the first group minus the
second the difference of the first group
and the third group and the difference
of the second group and the third group
these calculate difference differences
should now have the same variance this
assumption can be tested using marless
test of stcity when this assumption is
violated adjustments to the degrees of
freedom such as Greenhouse Geer or high
felt can be used independence of
observations this assumes that the
observations are independent of each
other this is a fundamental assumption
in a Nova and is usually assured by the
study design no significant outliers
outliers can have a disproportionate
effect on Anova potentially causing
misleading results it's important to
identify and address outliers let's
calculate an example and I'll show you
how to interpret the results let's say
this is our data that we want to analyze
we want to know whether therapy a b and
c and three different time points have
an effect on cholesterol levels each row
is one person the therapy is the between
subject factor and the time with the
levels before the therapy in the middle
and at the end of the therapy is the
within subject Factor so the first
patient on therapy a had a cholesterol
level of 165 before therapy a
cholesterol level of 145 in the middle
and a cholesterol level of 140 at the
end let's first calculate the example
online with data Tab and then discuss
how to interpret the results to
calculate an anova online simply go to
data.net and copy your data into this
table you can also load this example
data set using the link in the video
description then click on hypothesis
testing under this tab you will find a
lot of hypothesis test and depending on
which variable you click on you will get
an appropriate hypo hesis test suggested
if you copy your data up here the
variables will appear down here if the
correct scale level is not automatically
detected you can simply change it under
variables view for example if we click
on before middle and end a repeated
measures andova is automatically
calculated but we also want to include
the therapy so we just click on therapy
now we get a mixed model Anova we can
read the three null and the three
alternative hypotheses here then we get
the descriptive statistics output and
here we see the results of the analysis
of variance and also the post talk test
we'll look at these again in detail in a
moment but if you don't know exactly how
to interpret the results you can also
click on summary in
wordss but now back to the results most
important in this table are these three
rows with these three rows you can check
if the three n hypotheses we stated
before are rejected or not the first row
testal hypothesis whether cholesterol
level changes over time so whether the
therapies have an effect on cholesterol
level the second row tests whether there
is a difference between the respective
therapy forms with respect to
cholesterol level and the last row
checks if there is an interaction
between the two factors you can read the
P value in each case right at the back
here let's say we set the significance
level at 5% if our calculated P value is
less than
0.05 then the respective null hypothesis
is rejected and if the calculated P
value is greater than
0.05 then the null hypothesis is not
rejected thus we see here that the P
value of before middle and end is less
than
0.05 and therefore the values at before
middle and end are significantly
different in terms of cholesterol levels
the P value in the second row is greater
than
0.05 therefore the types of therapy have
no significant influence on the
cholesterol level it is important to
note that the mean value over the three
time points is considered here it could
also be that in one therapy the blood
pressure increases and in the other
therapy the blood pressure decreases but
on average over the time points the
blood pressure is the same if this was
the case however we would have an
interaction between the therapies and
the time we test this with the last
hypothesis in this case there is no
significant interaction between therapy
and time so there is an influence over
time but it does not matter which
therapy is used the therapy has no
significant influence if one of the two
factors has a significant influence the
following two tables show which of the
combinations differ significantly I hope
you enjoy the video and see you next
time